[Music]
oh
yeah just three dudes enjoying a coffee
that's right it's not really it's just
water uh listen
will if i can call you will you sure
kevin uh
the kevin o'brien show
we're back it's conan um come on
it's conan it's in the title of the show
conan it's conan yes all these years i
thought it was kevin o'brien you're such
a such a bad guy william what kind of
name is that oh yeah it's an irish name
an old celtic name but let's not talk
about memory let's talk
let's talk about you and then more about
me will yes
not too long ago i don't get to
socialize too much but uh andy uh you
and myself got together and we had what
i thought was a very nice meal it was it
was a very nice meal we went out for
dinner a little while ago it was a legit
just you know three guys hanging out
right uh and it was fun it would have
been uh you know it was it was great
with you guys being there and and uh
just because it would have been nice to
get a word in edgewise but uh other than
that it was great i thought we had a
good time no sorry i know you thought it
was fun right i thought it was great
and i mean it was probably for the best
yeah you loved the talking to me and
conan right yeah yeah yeah i felt like
conan was waiting for an audience didn't
you like that he just kept looking for
the the audience reaction
i don't like that i don't think i do
that like you just did i don't think i'd
do that you did a lot of that
you're saying during the meal i'd be
talking to you and then i'd be turning
into a camera that wasn't there yeah you
kept going i don't do that yeah
like four times
he said we'll be right back yeah yeah
yeah we did come back you're not the
first to criticize me about this i'm not
criticizing you and this is constructive
i'm your friend conan really i'm your
real friend kevin
it was fun though because and andy was
good he only had four martinis he was
driving yeah
he likes to watch me drinks i do yeah
that's actually true
when we when we've gone out before
sometimes he's disappointed if i don't
have
an alcoholic beverage that's actually
aren't you going to order something
today i almost want to tell the origin
of that story which is for andy's 40th
um andy and i went away just the two of
us just to get away
and um this one sounds very romantic
it's such a big uh no we didn't we went
out a couple of a bunch of us went and
uh and then my our friend peter and and
i encouraged amy to drink because we
just wanted to watch him drink i don't
know why it's making me laugh so
it is fun to watch him drink it i will
say that it's really good i did good i
did feel like i was performing for
creepy old men but you know
whatever you couldn't say it's my god
blues as my friend points out that's
what andy's for
keep smiling
that's a stupid song let's talk about
that's a great song um
you're an ass uh
will yes i can call you will sure your
voice i feel like we've been through
this yes
you've got the best voice in the
business incredible pipes we've talked
about this before you get a lot of voice
over work yeah uh you're the voice of a
lot of ads
i understand you're doing a cartoon now
is that correct yeah i'm part of the uh
the the new lego movie uh i'm voicing uh
the batman character which is gonna be
yeah
i know it seems there's a lego batman
yeah
do you not do the lego
well
if you what happens is that that parents
who spend time with their kids end up uh
they they build lego
in the um and my manager tells me my
children are fine i know they do
and i know
showbiz is your baby but listen uh show
business is my firstborn i know i know
it is buddy you're going to be good the
uh we uh uh i do i make a lot of legos
with my kids i mean i you know we build
a lot of which is my my son uh my
four-year-old will say uh you know can
we build the the lego fire station which
means can i build it can you build it
and i say sure and it ends up me
you know hunched over trying to read
these like danish you know instructions
which is just
pictures and then like if you get one
thing wrong you're screwed and i'm sort
of hunched over and then the entire time
he's going are we finished yet are we
finished yet i'm like i need the
two-piece flat top
where is it and then when it's finished
i'm so proud of it and then he breaks it
within two seconds i'm like no don't
break the thing
but but okay so but but so you you don't
seem like you enjoy legos yet you're the
voice of lego batman no that story was
illustrated how much i love it